nos piden expresar esta cantidad con
este formato 4500 es igual a tres
millares más espacio en blanco sentencia
bueno vamos a usar un código de colores
especial para que tengamos con un color
los millares y con otro las centenas y
así podamos trabajar más claramente
puede reescribir esto como 4000
más 500 que son mis centenas y esto es
igual a esta parte aquí ya son tres
millares pero yo aquí tengo cuatro mil o
cuatro millares entonces lo que tengo
que hacer aquí es de estos cuatro
millares nada más poner 33 mil y a esto
sumarle otros mil más mil aquí entre
estos dos ya tenemos los 4.000 más los
500 y ahora lo reescribimos nos va a
quedar 4.000 más 500 igual a 3.000 más
esto es parecido a lo que tenemos acá
pero no exactamente esto lo que tenemos
de este lado son los 4500 estos de acá
estos de acá son estos 4500 que es igual
estas pues son los dos millares esto lo
podemos dejar igual a tres millares pero
estos 1.500 nos están pidiendo
expresarlo en centenas
bueno aquí tenemos quince centenas
si nosotros multiplicamos 15% va a ser
igual a 1500 así que aquí tenemos 15
centenas y ahora si lo tenemos en el
formato como no los pidieron aquí arriba
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo